this is your first mango tango are you
excited to see um I'd be really excited
to see Taylor Swift but I'm not gonna be
here unfortunately cuz I've gotta catch
a flight to Denver but I know it's it's
heartbreaking it's heartbreaking but
what's happening in Denver um I gotta go
to Comic Con tomorrow yeah but uh I'll
see you soon I saw her yeah a couple
weeks ago but hopefully since she's the
best I love you you know what I love is
your new music video how did you get Wiz
Khalifa on the song listen it's a crazy
story
III was a huge risk Alisa Khalifa fan
going into that project so I was like as
soon as I heard the song I was like oh
my gosh
Wiz would be perfect for this and then
somehow we got was on it and two weeks
later the song was released and then we
just shot the music video together it's
just it's amazing your moves are so good
I was watching the behind-the-scenes
like we got access to that raw footage
can I get a little dance move thank you
people are also very obsessed with you
and your girlfriend and you've done
music videos with her yeah
will we ever hear you guys actually
collaborate on a song together hopefully
yeah hopefully in the future that'd be
really cool so yeah harder more fun to
be Instagram official to have all the
people commenting about you guys it's
cool it's really cool no they're the
best like I wouldn't be where I am
without my fans and like her fans are
great it's it's just amazing overall
it's so cool yeah and she's the best
what do you enjoy most about her on the
spot right now there's a lot of things
that love I love her smile I mean she's
like very supportive like she's
literally the best like and she makes me
laugh like constantly hello this is Sam
sequel yeah what do you know anything
have you talked the writers have you
talked to that talked to everybody
everyone yes we are getting a sequel and
we're getting a no I can't say that okay
I don't know yeah what am I gonna say um
it hasn't been confirmed yet but we need
to believe there's a sequel I mean the
first one did pretty well so hopefully
we get this thing shooting soon before
we grow up and I turn into him we don't
want that you know I love you Zeki it
happen sooner than we think where would
you like to see this
I'm very interested to see where Billy's
character development goes I mean
because he has superpowers and they find
his family it's like what's next what's
next I need to figure the bad guys so
who's next what's next for you more
music more music hopefully gonna release
an EP or an album soon I'm super excited
about that and new projects as well but
I'm not able to talk about yet but um so
much stuff that I'm just so excited
can't wait for you guys to see what is
the EP gonna sound like do you have any
more collaborations coming got a few
things that I'm so no comment no comment
but this give us a hearing there are
things in the works with some people
that I'm super excited to share about
that I've barely looked up to since I
was little so can you give us a hint guy
or girl what else okay what are we gonna
get it Oh Center soon okay I can't wait
I'm so excited
hello No thank you
[Music]